des zones d'ombre persistent dans
l'affaire de la femme retrouvée morte au
pied d'un arbre à Fondette un certain
nombre d'éléments laisse ta pensé qu'il
pourrait s'agir de la disparue depuis le
7 septembre dernier à la mambrole
surchoisie pourtant l'identité de la
victime n'est pas confirmé c'est en ces
termes que s'exprimait hier soir la
procureur de la République de Tours dans
un communiqué envoyé au médias le point
sur les derniers éléments de cette
macabre découverte avec Lucas Chopin on
n sait plus sur le corps de la femme
retrouvé ici dans ce bois de fond d'ette
par quatre chasseurs dans un communiqué
publié hier soir la procureur de la
République de tour explique que la
personne se trouvait en position
semi-assise adossée à un arbre et avec
des liens autour du cou alors s'agit-il
d'un suicide ou d'un homicide l'autopsie
pratiquée hier après-midi n'a pas permis
de répondre à cette question des examens
complémentaires des tissus et des
analyses toxicologiques ont été ordonné
quant à l'identité de la femme aucune
certitude pour le moment un certain
nombre d'éléments laissent à penser
qu'il pourrait s'agir de la personne
disparue depuis le 7 septembre dernier à
la mambrol sur choisie explique la
procureur hier certains journalistes ont
affirmé que la femme avait été
formellement identifiée comme étant la
disparue de la mambrole nous avons
contacté ce midi Abed benjador l'avocat
du père qui dém cette information au
moment où nous l'avons joint aucun
élément en ce sens n'avait été porté à
sa connaissance et le père demeurait
dans l'attente d'une éventuelle
identification pour l'heure les
investigations se poursuivent sous la
direction du parquet de tour d'autres
informations pourrai nous parvenir
rapidement